un service au volant bien spéciale
moisson québec l'a vu sa clientèle
doublé depuis le début de la pandémie
n'est pas de 35 mille quatre cents
personnes personnes
aidé par noah à 70 milles et plus à
montréal l'organisme à augmenter sa
cadence de 35% depuis avril mais je n'ai
le 38 2 5 millions de dollars de
nourriture qui vraisemblablement serait
elle à l'enfouissement terre est si on
ne l'avait pas capté suffisamment vite
cette nourriture leur fils à ses 10
millions de dollars de l'autre de plus
que ce qu'on avait donné l'année patrie
pour suivre le rythme moisson montréal a
bénéficié de l'aide des employés de la
ville pour remplacer les bénévoles en
confinement et sa liste de donateurs a
grimpé en flèche
aujourd'hui on n'est pas en situation
d'urgence financièrement mais enfin les
écureuils parce que on dit demain sur
une contraction économique se valent et
des projets privés
en plus du reste lakovic 19 a chamboulé
le réseau bioalimentaire bien des
produits ne trouvent plus preneur auprès
des hôtels et des restaurants pour aider
les agriculteurs le gouvernement fédéral
a mis sur pied le programme de
récupération d'aliments excédentaire
plus de 22 millions $ seront remis à la
banque alimentaire canada et ceux qui
restent faut pouvoir distribuer à
travers le réseau de banques
alimentaires des hommes des des légumes
des fruits de mer du poisson de la
viande
alors c'est vraiment de regarder tous
les produits excédentaires et puis de
distribuer sol de façon équitable à
travers le réseau ce programme s'ajoute
aux 100 millions de dollars octroyés en
avril dernier par justin trudeau en
plein coeur de la crise dont la moitié a
été remise à banques alimentaires canada
nous sommes et nous sommes émus vraiment
le soutien des canadiens a été
extraordinaire à montréal richard dano
pense ou chemin parcouru
la société québécoise la guerre
ces quelques phrases ont prié par son
sens que l'union d'air pendant la
pandémie c'est probablement des des très
belles choses
je sais très émouvant parce que ici
marie josée paquet comme radio canada
montréal